we should do Cody and we'll do this
5v5 yeah
for sure we're on a team of five okay
and we fight another and we tap right
away both of us
so then it's just three hours
yikes and aren't the three other guys
like what the [__] sorry man we're
completely out of nothing sorry you guys
you guys you guys got it you're good we
love you no y'all boys are strong you
guys are awesome teammates we love you
guys get in there come on get in there I
have a visual event one two three go
yikes yeah
yeah
we're good man yeah we should do a five
verse five like podcasters League
okay like imagine us versus Michael
Bisping
what they were talking about fighting
right yeah we'll go against Michael
Bisping Trail sun and are they
podcasters yeah they have podcasts yeah
what are you thinking though US versus
Rhett and Link it doing what fighting
they're so tall
[Laughter]
would be like what the [__]
it'd be a very like what the [__] is
it'd be it'd be like Elon and
oh we should talk about that in a second
but uh
no us fighting Rhett and Link that would
just be the northmen well we just tap
right away anyway so yeah that's true
yeah oh that's really funny man
yo we should oh my God that'd be such an
inside bit what we everyone listening to
the podcast now will know but what if we
joined the next crater clash and we hype
it up like we're gonna [__] kill each
other right away yeah as soon as we walk
in dude oh my God both of our coaches
just stand up and throw the towels we
walk through the center of the Ring
hey thank you yeah yeah yeah dude you
are a Class Act bro you're a Class Act
love you man love you everyone's like oh
yeah sorry I got scared yeah
cold crowd the stadiums like
sorry guys you threw in the towel
straight away what were you thinking my
uh my feet hurt the shoes are just very
tight they wrap my hands weird
so a little too tight so yeah I just
didn't want to get punched
so thank you for having me appreciate it
while we're having out there of my
Eczema it's starting to I don't know
it's just kind of flaring up inside the
wrap so like I think I just need to
leave do you think you'll get in the
ring again
no no
not too scary yeah
and I'm really itchy yeah what happened
we threw in the towel straight away yeah
I have like a massive fever
I thought it would be good but like I'm
kind of really sick right now
someone comes up with that covered gun
it's like 105.
I just tested positive this morning and
I feel [__] horrible yeah I thought
it'd be fine I thought I had like three
days before it kicked in but it's
hitting like right now
what happened yeah what happened to you
out there I think I have covid I just
tested positive for Ebola
this morning
right massively contagious
what happened to you out there
um I have some like untreated gonorrhea
yeah yeah
herpes flaring up badly the trunks feels
so bad right now I have to go this is
open folds cold cold
I gotta poop yeah
you know that's had to have happened so
many times yeah
a first-time fighter just tapping right
away and then going
yeah to the bucket
oh no I thought you're gonna say doing
this are you okay yeah I just gotta poop
so bad I think you're gonna say the
bucket that they used for the ice yeah
yeah I go right up to a drop trowel
to unload in there
all right I'm good let's go yeah like
you already tapped so you can't it's
like ah I thought that was pause
everyone's mad at you when they see you
[__] in the ring the whole crowd
universally goes huh
yeah now we get it
Handler handle it man you're a warrior
dude we'll see you next time
you're a champion bro it's all good we
get it man that's the that's the
ultimate get out of jail free card right
there which you threw in the towel what
happened I have diarrhea yeah oh yeah
yeah oh
sorry yeah and coven
well what do you think of the Elon and
Mark fight let them kill each other
that's awesome yeah I guess I think this
is just I don't know
they should fight for pink slips of what
to the [__] company yeah put it
online that'd be the fight card put it
on the line that's sick and we
co-headlined yeah
I'd give the company to anyone and they
shut it down yeah no no we we put both
of our YouTube channels on the line and
we just exchanged
yeah I'm tired of being me yeah you can
have me so we fight each other
we put our channels on the line
we both tap immediately and we just Swap
and then we swap and delete each other's
channels yeah
what happened out there I got scared
yeah didn't want to didn't want him to
do YouTube anymore yeah I'm afraid that
would actually be hard as [__] if we
just combine just scrubbed our channels
everyone would be like yo
legendary
we like yeah they just got in there they
sh they no you know me crazy
we beat the [__] out of each other like
even when they go ding ding ding round
over we just keep going and then we
throw in the towel simultaneously
and when we're both just like it's a
draw and we're bleeding
and then our teams each walk out a
laptop and we're holding each other's
channels we delete it live
everyone will go we dab each other up
and no one ever believes us ever again
yeah and then they're like yeah do you
guys wait hold on you have anything to
say we both grabbed the mic and in
unison we're like podcast over yeah no
nothing ever uploaded again
what the [__] [__]
hard as hell bro yeah that'd be sick
that'd be the way to go out yeah
we literally don't do a single piece of
media for the rest of our life yeah we
just go back to writing code
what the [__] having a cardinal they
just beat the [__] out of each other and
they just canceled themselves
they deleted that nobody knows where
they are they're just everything's gone
yeah and they use what money they earn
from media to hire a legal team to
delete any clip about them
you can't find them anymore
so what do they do I heard they work at
like a restaurant
they're just somewhere they're somewhere
yeah yeah
did you go back to coding that's a good
job no they said [__] that too yeah
so
Cody's a surf instructor
someone goes to oh you're no no filming
yeah yeah yeah yeah please
all right guys today we're gonna learn
how to tackle a small wave
and teach a little something about big
wave later on
all right gang we'll see in the bonus
it's gonna be 60 Minutes of Limp Biscuit
[Laughter]
just one of those days baby
it's all about the he said she said
[__] [__] bull crap
think you better quit it
yeah or you get hit with the fat lip
yeah what is that what is that lyric I
keep butchering it
we've been really Canadian this episode
have we a lot of apologies yeah sorry I
cut you off sorry sorry I cut you off
um
what's what's that [__] say I think you
better quit let that [__] slip
or you'll be leaving him with a fat lip
what does that he says she says bull
stink
laughs